10 Dark Facts You Never Knew About Good Star
Wars Characters (“10 dark facts about good
star wars characters” may work better since
it’s hard to be secret about the leads and
the canon isn’t that big yet etc)
We all love our Star Wars heroes.
From standing up against tyranny to being
all around great individuals who inspire the
best in us, the heroes are often our favourite
characters.
But even the light can sometimes be caught
in a bit of darkness, which can help humanize
the of this galaxy heroes.
Here are Screenrant’s 10 dark facts you
never knew about star wars characters.
Obi Wan Kenobi
Master to Anakin Skywalker and brief mentor
to Luke, Obi Wan Kenobi is a fan favorite
Jedi who fought as a General during the Clone
Wars.
But Obi Wan also had some shady things happening
on the side and some questionable ethics in
play.
Obi Wan has been caught lying multiple times
to Luke Skywalker as well as bending the truth
and omitting facts from the young Jedi’s
training.
Also, in Episode III, he ventures to Mustafar
with intent to murder his former apprentice
instead of trying to bring him back to the
light.
Luke trained in a swamp and was able to do
it, a mentor and a friend with decades of
Jedi knowledge should’ve known better than
to go in with intent to kill.
Yoda
One of the most powerful and wisest of the
Force users, Yoda stands as a beacon for overcoming
the odds, no matter how small you are against
them.
But even the smartest and strongest of us
all and fears and darkness inside of them
and it’s no surprise to learn that Yoda’s
darkest fear is actually himself.
In the final season of Clone Wars, Yoda searches
for the answers to everlasting life (or how
to become a force ghost) and faces ever increasing
trials.
One such trial sees him enter a duel with
the manifestation of his inner dark side.
The darkness points out that Yoda spends his
time at war, surrounded by the decadence of
war and thus, the darkness is free to grow
inside of him.
The only way to be rid of the spectral force
was for Yoda to honestly admit that it did
indeed reside inside himself.
Talk about inner conflicts!
Maz Kanata
Fans came to learn of Maz Kanata in the Force
Awakens, a small orange alien who was in tune
with the Force and in possession of Anakin’s
old saber.
However, when she’s not dropping Force 101
on young minds, she’s actually a feared
pirate queen.
Offering credits, work, equipment and connections
to smugglers, Maz is heavily involved in the
criminal underworld and will not think twice
about throwing anyone in jail for breaking
her house rules.
Han Solo
When he’s not shooting down aliens in cantinas
(sorry George, that happened), Han Solo was
known for his smuggling skills, being a liar
and the determination to do anything to get
the score done.
One such move was getting revenge on a crime
lord.
In order to pull the heist, Han illegitimately
married Sana Starros to make the ruse convincing.
However, after the job was done, Han stole
her share of the cut and abandoned her!
Scurffy looking nerf herder indeed.
Luke Skywalker
Hero of the original trilogy, Luke has had
a fascinating arc from whiney farm boy to
Jedi Master.
But the road proved challenging for Luke as
he often wrestled with the dark side.
In return of the jedi, donning black robes
and a hood, Luke Skywalker straight up Force
chokes one of Jabba’s guards at the palace.
A move commonly associated with the Sith and
other Dark Side users, Luke seems to balance
both the darkness and light in him, being
illustrated in the film’s climax when his
black robes come loose as he parts ways with
his father, revealing the white material underneath.
Anakin Skywalker
The chosen one himself, it’s no secret that
Anakin has had his fair share of dark moments.
From murdering a village of tusken raiders
to you know, killing younglings, Anakin has
done his fair share before donning the black
suit.
However, Anakin had a prelude to all his darkness
in the Mortis arc on the Clone Wars television
show.
In this arc, he meets the Father, Son and
Daughter on the planet Mortis and is ultimately
given a vision of his dark future.
However, Anakin keeps this vision to himself
and does not bring it up to anyone’s attention,
forever sealing his downfall.
Mace Windu
As one of the most powerful members on the
Jedi Council, Mace Windu is a force to be
reckoned with when it comes to lightsaber
combat.
Heck, he technically bested Darth Sidious
in a duel.
But Windu has an ace up his sleeve that most
Jedi don’t have: Windu is able to use both
the light and dark side of the force, hence
his purple saber.
In the novel “dark disciple”, Windu even
goes to the extreme as to suggest and implement
the straight up assassination of Count Dooku,
something that goes against the very code
he’s sworn to protect.
Chewbacca
We all love Chewie, the furry side kick and
best friend to Han Solo.
Just don’t get on his bad side.
Chewie, like most wookies are insanely strong
and no problem using violence against anyone
who gets in their way.
In fact, in the novelization for the Force
awakens and a deleted scene, Chewie rips out
Unklar Plutt’s arms from his sockets after
the junker confronted Rey and himself in Maz
Kanata’s castle.
Ezra Bridger
The protagonist of the popular TV show Rebels,
Ezra has been portrayed as a boy who is slowly
balancing the light side and the dark.
However, it was the season 3 premiere that
really surprised fans when Ezra mind controlled
the pilot of an AT-DP walker, forcing him
to shoot down his allies before making the
pilot walk off a platform while still in the
walker in a terrible act of forced suicide.
It’s a really dark moment for the show and
character and illustrates just how powerful
the Sith Holocrons can be.
Rey
Many fans fell in love with Rey in the Force
Awakens, the 2015 sequel to the Return of
the Jedi.
The film was the first time a female character
was the lead and she instantly won over legions
of fans for her determination, personality
and adept skills and, well, just about everything.
But even Rey had a moment of darkness unknown
to most fans.
In the canon novelization, Rey temporarily
embraces the dark side during the duel with
Kylo Ren.
When on his back in the snow, she hears a
voice in her head encouraging her to kill
the fallen Jedi.
Those are our picks for Good Star Wars characters
that have had dark moments.
Do you agree with our list?
Can you think of any good characters, Canon
or Expanded Universe who had their own moments
of darkness?
Let us know in the comments and don’t forget
to subscribe for more videos like this!